la la la la mohammad rasool allah
bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Dean show we in
this show are going to be talking about
the prophets we've talked about them in
the past shows with our special guest
who's coming out inshallah God willing
in just a minute we talked about the
first man Adam his mission what he
called the people to the way of life
that he lived we established that all
the profits of Noah Abraham the ones
that came before them after them they
all call to the same way that way of
surrender submission sincerity obedience
and all of this in peace to the One God
they didn't come teaching different
religions with each messenger so we're
going to continue talking about some of
the messengers that followed and with
our next guest who is a former Christian
preacher we've had him on the show many
times in the past and we're excited to
have him here with us today when we come
back out check use of Estes talking
about the profits be right back love
there's only one
is his messenger Allah like in the world
o Allah there's only one but Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice all
of the profits would have been labeled
Muslims because this essential message
was the same in essence submission this
is God talking to you how can I stand
behind the Pope on Sunday morning and
preach a sermon that I knew was at
variance with the actual taproot of
Christianity
Michael che guest is highly gonna sit
down welcome to LA it's nice to be back
on the show it's nice to have you back
with us again now people know about you
they have seen some of our shows that we
done with you in the past they heard
your story about how you came to Islam
you were former Christian preacher your
father was a minister yeah we didn't
have our own church the other way but we
did work with other churches and we had
when we get an opportunity to go and
speak of course we would but we did a
lot of stuff behind the scenes yeah my
dad started the concerned Christian
centers and we used to help them raise
money for bus ministries and things like
this yeah we were really active hands on
guys and we had our own businesses we'd
never needed to take one penny from any
ministry by the way our money came from
our other business endeavors now you
adjusted your life a little bit you live
in life according to how all the
messengers live life that's I wouldn't
go that far I that sounds pretty austere
and it sounds pretty righteous and I
don't consider myself that but I am
trying to learn more about what the real
message of the prophets was and when
they brought it and how we can implement
it in our lives yeah so you made another
adjustment used to worship Jesus now
you're worshiping the one that created
Jesus we had a concept that Jesus was a
god or a son of a god a part of a god or
something like that so in a sense even
when we said well you know we don't
worship Jesus the man or they worship
Jesus the god that's in there and so and
so on but it is confusing to many people
and so the beautiful thing about Islam
it straightens out a lot of the previous
message when it came we don't consider
as Muslims in your notice we don't
consider that Muhammad came along peace
be upon him with a brand new religion a
new message that in fact we say that
he's calling people back to the original
message which came with all the prophets
Adam he trees Abraham Moses Solomon
David so on today I thought may it be a
good idea to kind of pick up where we
left over talking about Moses a little
bit we know that he was Moses in the
bull rushes
story the Bible we have the same thing
in Islam that his mother did put him in
the little basket and set him down the
river to keep him from being killed
because they were killing the firstborn
of the sons of the slaves who were the
Jews at that time yes so that was and
I'm sure she's not the only woman they
did it uh-huh but it was that particular
baby that was picked up by somebody for
the house of Pharaoh and she was excited
to have this baby and she wanted
somebody to help erase it because it
would just cry and cry and cry and cry
so there was a girl NASA's girl did she
know anybody who had a baby that could
wet nurse you know suckle this baby and
the girl City I know one and she brought
a lady and who is the lady she brought
the very mother of Moses so she got to
see her son again and she actually was
helping raise her own son yeah oh yeah
this story's a nice story but what is
that going to do for you to me today now
all that I just said what is the benefit
do you have anybody killing your oldest
son no you got a room Nile rivers
running buddy that's going to put your
kid in there no there's these kinds of
things just are interesting to note to
compare to other stories but I want to
find something's going to benefit me
today that when I walk out in the street
I've got something to hang on to that
will benefit me help me get through the
day better so that's why we'll go to
some of the things that he encountered
in his life that were problematic we
already discussed what happened when he
hit somebody and killed them we said
that so you can't say that's an accident
you can say it was an accident on his
side as far as it wasn't what he
intended yes for the fact they hit
somebody even hitting somebody in Islam
is wrong you don't have the permission
to strike a person unless they've struck
you and then only to the extent that
they hit you you can't hit them twice if
they hit you once can't hit him hard if
they hit you soft so for a problem to do
something like that that would be a sin
on him and he'd have to repent for that
but it wouldn't be a major sin like some
people would attribute and say that you
know things that they've said about
these prophets we would miss at that
it's also interesting to note that when
we look at the lives of these prophets
that they did come with a message that
was very applicable to their time period
let's take that for example at the time
of Moses there was a lot of emphasis on
magic yes it tells us in the Quran about
it as well we find the first instance
here about black magic and how it comes
about and at the time period that it
came it came in Iraq and it at the time
of it Baghdad and it was many many many
millennium ago and Allah sent down to
angels not Devils to angels to teach
people this black magic this magic it's
called satyr yes when the people saw it
and how it worked then they were ordered
not to do it so it was purposely done to
tempt people just like the fruit was the
tempt Adam they were showing this black
magic and then they were telling the
people don't do it don't do it don't do
it and of course people did it we still
people doing black magic today things
that caused a strife or a problem
between a husband and wife and yet in
divorce something to get like put a
spell on somebody almost to make them
want to marry somebody that they
wouldn't ordinarily married things like
this this is the kind of stuff they
practice by the way it won't really work
on anybody who Allah is protecting so if
somebody's a real believer trusting in a
law then you protect them from it but it
is real thing now at the time of Moses
magic was a big thing so here were these
court magicians who were doing all kinds
of magic that was really fake stuff that
they made
to scare people to make people think
that they had power and they were saying
they got their power from the king
they're feral yes and how that works is
that as long as people believe that the
king is the one with all this magic he's
letting these magicians do it and so on
then he gets them to give their money
over to him there authority over to him
and he takes over and acts like a big
shot he's another one as we discussed
with the subject of Abraham here's
another person saying to the people he's
a god yes and he wants people to worship
Him obey Him and everything and of
course a lot isn't like that that's
wrong so Moses is being sent to Pharaoh
the very house where he was raised he
was raised in the house afire then I say
house of Pharaoh I don't mean that
particular Pharaoh by the way yes it's
believed that that the Pharaoh that
actually brought him in was dead at the
time of him being full grown and having
the message and it was either a son or
some descendant you see of that feral
now so this would be somebody more of a
contemporary somebody closer to the age
of Moses to and what he comes with is
first the message to say that these are
the children of Israel let them go let
them worship their God leave them be
don't treat them like this and of course
a pharaoh is going to say well I'm God
you don't tell me what to do so Allah
sent signs along with Moses to disprove
this business of these magicians yes and
whereas the magician's would throw out
these ropes that they had which they had
some kind of wire thing or threads or
something attached to it make it look
like they were snakes and move them
around you know where the people not
knowing how they did it kind of creating
an illusion definitely illusions yeah so
Allah is telling Moses you stretch out
your stick now they had ropes that
became snakes but he told Moses just
take that stick that you walk with even
asked Moses what is that you got he says
this dick and I use it for this and that
he said I want you to stretch it
out and when you do it's going to become
a snake and sure enough that's exactly
what happened when Pharaoh called his
magicians forward and said here now do
your magic scare the people and they
start doing their magic and of course
the people are like oh oh oh look out
look out maybe that snake will bite you
or whatever then Moses stretches out his
stick and it becomes a real snake a big
real snake and it goes around and eats
up their ropes or their trick things and
then when he stretches out his hand
again it turns back into a state mm-hmm
that's when the magician's say okay
that's enough for us this is a real real
profit we'll be right back easily Xena
coming to the truth requires two things
that requires deep thinking that you've
already done but it requires another
step and that's courage if you have the
truth but you don't have courage you
won't stand up for the truth and that's
as good as standing up for falsehood I
would say this thing that you just told
me it's not in the scripture and they
would say a marginal note added by
scribe yeah okay we know that and I'd be
thinking if you know this is not the
Bible why are you preaching it as if
it's gospel truth what happened to these
magicians next now that you said they
saw the snakes they said this is a real
profit oh well they said we believe in
him and his God so they disbelieved now
in faro as being a god but they probably
didn't believe anyway but they said no
no we believe in the real God they got a
Moses now Farrell is going to take
exception to that immediately and say
well how dare you in front of all these
people I'm paying you to say that I'm
the guy behind all the magic and how
dare you and he's accusing them now
you've got some kind of allegiance going
on here to Moses and you're just trying
to overthrow me now so by golly I'm
going to punish you for what you've done
and he ordered that to have their aren't
their limbs cut off on opposite sides
arm and leg on opposite sides and
crucified them and they said we don't
care what you do because we're never
believed in you and we do believe in him
as being a prophet and
as being a representative the one true
God and they didn't mind even time and
the wife of pharaoh was another amazing
case because she also believed and if i
was really upset you know my own wife
believing in this yeah so what was the
message here is the things that came
with Moses the water turning into blood
putting his hand in his co pulling it
out it is whitey like it looked like
shining now the Bible says leprosy but
that wouldn't make a lot of sense but it
pulled it out and it was shining like a
light and he put it back in and we
pulled it out was normal again another
thing that happened was the locusts that
came and all of these things were being
predicted by Moses saying you've got to
let them go or you're going to have
these disasters come on you and he said
I don't believe you but then when the
disaster would call me and say well okay
okay take it away and I'll keep my end
of the bargain and let them go but as
soon as the disaster was over he'd say
well not really or his advisers might
tell him you know don't listen to him
and keep them enslaved until finally
they were after the death of his son
farrell finally just got weak he said
that's it go just get him out of here
well when they left they come up against
the Red Sea well we go now so even own
some of Moses's own people began to
ridicule him look you took us away we
were in safety over there and now you
got us messed up at least if we were
over there but who was saying it were
the ones that were not doing the hard
brick work they were the ones that were
a little higher up in that
superstructure well now when they're got
this water on the one side of them can't
go anywhere and here comes Pharaoh and
his troops army is coming for them and
they're saying oh we were better off
left alone in New Ian but now Allah is
showing Moses stretcher stick out again
well this time I didn't become a snake
by slapping the top of the water with
that stick then Allah caused the water
to open and part and it said that they
crossed it without even getting their
feet wet at all
all and I all the way to the other side
Farrell's going in after now Farrell
must have been really on somethin weird
because what was he doing what was he
thinking you know you see that water
part like that you just go in there
after them what haven't you figured it
out yet but when people don't want to
believe and especially when they're in a
rage then they're liable to do anything
and this is the mentality he had he knew
better but he did it anyway went after
them and then Allah caused the water to
close in on him as he was drowning he
said I believe in the Lord of Moses now
that makes that would most people say
well that makes him a believer he died
of liver no because when you said at the
last minute that doesn't count yeah when
you even it when you're knowing you're
gonna die and now you're ready ok I'm
going to die anyway let me go ahead and
say that no no and he didn't save my god
he didn't say I believed in the Lord of
the Worlds he said or under the universe
he just said I believe in his God and so
for whatever reason he didn't get saved
but Allah said we will save him in his
body hmm well save him in his body and
he will be a sign for all times and it's
interesting to note that dr. Maurice
bahay the french surgeon and scientists
who was called in to study about well
maybe 40 years ago or so he was called
in to study one of the Egyptian mummies
yeah and while he was studying and he
they were doing some forensic studies on
it they came to conclusion he didn't die
a normal death he drowned the other
thing was I said his body was not
embalmed yet it was preserved and they
became amazing he said this is to amazes
the from my Bible and they said well the
were Muslims you know there's a gypped
and they said that we know that this is
very likely because his being here like
this preserved without preservatives or
without embalming is the fitting of the
scripture of the quran because the Quran
says this yes that a would be a
sign not only would he be preserved by
the sign and now he's on tour the same
one if that's Moses there it's been
taken around and people staring at
looking at and look at that mummy yeah
so these were the events that happened
that we get from the verbatim word of
God the Quran that talked about Moses
and the unique situations that he was
because the people at that time were
focusing on that subject Allah sent
somebody with those qualities to show to
them that this is good only be for my
law now the next one would let us talk
about in a couple centuries a couple
millenniums ago we talked about 2,000
years ago the Greeks and Romans and so
on had a big influence and impact on the
people the Romans were running the show
at that stage and they were focusing
everything about medicine medicine all
about medicine trying to find ways to
live forever to live better to be
healthy that was a big thing to be very
super healthy back then you know so when
Jesus peace be upon him came this is a
focus here that he did miracles that
they were not able to do to give a blind
person site to cure a leper of leprosy
skin diseases to have someone who was a
[ __ ] thats could suddenly walk and
then finally the ultimate of all things
and this was definitely assigned to
everybody regardless if they were Jewish
or if they were a pig and more spur an
atheist a man who's dead for I think it
Bible says four days but Lazarus is dead
and he comes back to life now how do you
explain that and that was known that
that happened and these were things they
wish they could do but couldn't do and
here a lot shorter no this is definitely
a representative so this brings us to
another area of our discussion about
profits we've already mentioned that
they all come with the same message and
we also said that they had to have a
great character but when they come with
message and verification miracles called
in Arabic Medusa
when they're coming when watch it's a
it's in it it's going to be clear to
anybody who sees it how can you explain
this so now we're talking about Jesus we
went from Moses peace be upon him to
Jesus peace be upon so there's another
problem with like again I don't want to
just say everything in chronological
order because it's not forever would be
skipping over too much of it but there
was another one an Arab prophet by the
name of Sally many ancient millenniums
back before any of this and he was
telling his people to come to the
worship the one true God and to obey Him
pray to Him and be good people be
morally upright don't do bad things yes
well these people were really tough case
they lived in a desert where they only
had a one well yes ok and they were
saying that because they would prey to
these false gods to get water to come
out you know from there well and he
still don't pray to God and they said we
will never believe and let you bring us
a sign well what kind of sign do you
want oh here they come up with a good
one they said ok there was a big boulder
huge rock they said make that crack open
like an egg and make a pregnant camel
come out of it some hard two moons here
first of all how do you crack open a
boulder like an egg and then it's hollow
inside and it has a camel and none of
that the camel is pregnant they said
they'll believe that yeah ok and a lot
made it happen the rock split out comes
a camel and she's pregnant now how did
she get pregnant inside of a rock how
did she come out of her I mean this is
so bizarre that there is no possible way
anybody can explain this this is either
the wildest tail in the world or it is
such a miracle that you don't have any
option except to believe because you
named it you said do this and it's
something impossible to do then it was
done so now why don't you want to
believe in God but it comes with the
condition I was the other thing I would
tell you about
come with these big miracles that come
with condition that after it comes you
don't have an option anymore to say well
I didn't know maybe this maybe that you
either believe or a great and horrible
punishment will come in this life and
then the next life and that's why Noah
was upset with his people he knew if
they didn't believe they're going to be
punished they would drown that's also
why Jonah was worried Eunice why he was
concerned about his people not I'm
accepted he knew a great punishment was
going to come on them and sure enough
and when he come back they had all
accepted we see the consistent message
what you telling us that these
messengers they call people to worship
one God none of them are so far calling
people to worship themselves so Saints
idols etc now we left off of Jesus peace
be upon a no we left off with this is
the she-camel the she-camel yeah yeah
because here we are what happened did
they all accept it yeah initially they
didn't have any choice cuz i mean you
know if you didn't then you'd be the
idiot because you said you know you
wanted something miraculous thing it
happened okay so now are you going to
say about it but the deal comes now a
test comes to them and this test is that
they're not allowed to drink out of that
well every other day yes why is because
this camel she's going to drink it dry
she could consume the entire contents of
the well then it would be water that
following day and they'd have to draw
extra water out for themselves to be
able to sustain the day with no water
then the next day they could get water
again and so on in this continued till
one of me got fed up with he said why we
have to wait for this camel and why does
she get to drink all our water and we
don't need her and so he kills her this
is mentioned in Quran he killed her yes
and for this for this not for killing a
camel again this is not the point but
for this such huge disobedience you've
been given a sign you've seen the
miracle you asked for and then you've
been told now you have to let her drink
and you blew it you blew the test and
instead of letting her drink he killed
her so he and all those with him that
were on that
mentality or destroyed Allah sent a big
thing to the big wind came on them there
was once people are devoted and
destroyed by raining fire on them and
others were destroyed by a great wind
and then another that were destroyed by
a big sound a sound that came through
that wiped him out no it's amazing but
each time they had a profit that came a
warning that came a sign that they saw
and then something they have to do
afterwards for instance with Jesus when
he came he had his miracles his people
needed to believe in him and all they
had to believe it he is the chosen one
he's the king he's the chosen he's the
Messiah he's the Christ if you believe
that then you're okay and of course act
on what he taught he told people that
you have to obey the commandments if you
break even at least of the commandments
and teach that you'll be the least in
the kingdom I'm taking that from Matthew
5 17 but the point that it comes out of
this real clear Jesus is telling keep
the commandments if you love me you'll
love the father and keep the
commandments this is a clear teaching so
how could anybody come along and say
well then somebody else came later and
said no you don't have to keep them
anymore so this would be the complete
and physicists what Paul say came with
something opposite now where God
Almighty and Jesus is saying keep the
commandments and you have Paul who's
coming with something different would
this be in line with what the exactly
the point that I was driving home but I
don't like to you know in a television
program I don't like to say it too
harshly because some people get the idea
all your you don't believe in a Pauline
doctrine but actually there is no
authentic manuscript from Paul today
everything we've got our copies of
copies is something that we don't know
how much of it has been interpolated we
don't know what it's been played with
but somebody somewhere along the line
wrote that it was okay to break these
Commandments live for instance
circumcision was no longer the for flesh
as it always had been even Jesus was
circumcised himself but this whoever
wrote the doctor
tation saying no it's a circumcision of
the heart well what is that supposed to
mean anyway Circle your heart cut out
your heart it doesn't make any sense but
for those who want to believe that
they'll be upset with me because I've
said this you know they don't want to
hear that any more than those people
wanted to hear that some of the message
that came with their profits but we come
now the Prophet Muhammad and with
Prophet Muhammad it is very clear that
he came with one of the greatest of all
miracles that ever came that was the
Quran itself which still exists in
totality in the original form in Arabic
language now before you talk about the
cron is there any miracles that he did
name a couple because we're going to
have to have you back to wrap this
series up of the prophets we're almost
out of time is there any living miracles
that he did during that time I don't
know what you mean by a living miracle
but we know i mean the living miracles
the Crom but miracles at that time that
he did well we know that the moon split
they they asked for something this is
like a minute oh yeah okay they asked
his people asked him to come up with
something and he like the camel coming
out of this rock and they wanted the
moon to split and the moon was split and
yay they saw it on both sides of the
mountain of light called Java newer and
they verified it even with some people
who had been in the desert and there
were travelers and when they came to
town they asked him and they serif I'd
they also had seen it on the same night
and that's just one of many the water
came from his fingers and gave water /
the people to drink there were animals
that spoke and confirm that he was the
Prophet there were many things that
happen and there's a chain of narration
is that witnesses that witness all this
that we have absolutely not only we know
it's not just something that we have
written that it's something that we can
tell you who said it and who these
people were where they got it from cuz
all you talk about that in the next
month okay we're going to have to do one
more to come to a conclusion tell us you
mentioned Jesus and Muhammad peace be
upon them all closing this show was
there any difference in their mess
the essential message doesn't change
worship God without any partners the
other thing to come along with it are
going to be the test that comes to the
people due to the miracles that have
come along with it as well does it make
sense yeah why don't we talk about that
in the next thank you for being with us
again we're going to love you back to do
another one in sha Allah okay and I hope
that everyone who's been watching this
series with sheikh yusuf estes you can
visit the Dean show calm and you'll see
where we started off with the first man
Adam we covered Noah we covered Moses
Abraham and I hope you could see the
consistency that the message has always
been the same submit to God do what God
wants you to do obey him on his terms
and we're going to do another show
inshallah God willing to continue
talking about the last and final
messenger no more messages to come the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
the living miracle that he came with the
Quran so you don't want to miss that
next show keep turning in every week to
the Dean show calm until next time I
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you you
have to pray as if everything depends on
a lot it does but you must work
everything depends on you it does that's
my point you see on the same and I don't
like that I don't like us sitting here
what are you waiting for what are we
waiting for right now what are you
waiting for all these people to come to
this line what are you waiting for what
are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come to
logon bring these people lots of fun
tomorrow put in our hand the ability to
do it now do your job it's cold it lay
everybody sleeping I arise and ask a lot
of thinking me Omar you see hola you
know all the sins I do I turn to you to
figure my sing tomorrow I'm you seen for
slave you're my love alone I'm the one
runs away oh the guide me